he is Jason Mockingjay how you doing
Jason doing I'm doing well buddy it's
been a while but we're homies for life
brother no no well you know that it's
been a long while since NFL Network but
I spoke to you yesterday on your on your
local local airwaves
you brought some gravitas production
thank you pleasure that's what I bring I
bring that in truckloads the gravitas
around man it's going out of your pocket
I try you've got it everywhere all right
bro so what's going on with the NFL
right now in the decision for in
relation to everything going on with the
kovin madness Jason I'll give you the
floor on the corners meeting and the NFL
the new league year in the draft well
you know yeah I'm hearing from multiple
team employees that it's their
understanding that the league meetings
west palm beach in a month will not go
on as planned I reached out to the NFL
about that was basically told yeah we'll
have something official on that stay
tuned the draft you know they've got
more time between now and the draft but
as we talked about yesterday rich anyone
who has to be there including agents who
represent players who would ostensibly
be invited top 20 tight picks don't want
to be there you know what I mean and
they don't know how they're gonna go
into these these kids houses and sit
down with their moms and say yeah you
know just got everything that's going on
there's gonna be a private on a private
plane for us and it'll be okay you know
it'll be a couple hundred thousand
people in Vegas like I just don't know
how you sell that on a multitude of
levels unless there is some drastic
recalibration and how this virus is
spreading in this country you know in
the next few weeks so they're not in a
rush to make any decisions but the way
things are trending I don't know anybody
in the league who thinks that that's
going to go as planned again unless
there is a major course correction in
how the you know and how the virus is
being handled and how it's spreading in
terms of the lead year the league is
sending out vibes that nothing to see
here but what you know how that goes
sometimes right a little bit of a trial
balloon and how many calls do we get
from team presidents and owners and how
many clubs are letting us know well hey
we're not bringing players to our
facility so we're not going to be able
to consummate deals fully because we're
not
some 155 million dollars guaranteed
until they pass a physical just we're
not going to be conducting any physicals
and work you know what I mean we told
people to essentially stay home and if
it was up to us we closed our facilities
entirely so it may be business as usual
but it ain't really business as usual
interesting I did not think of that
aspect because I've been just sitting
here saying for the last hour plus like
yeah I mean this stuff can be conducted
by phone in terms of contracts but when
you're talking about multi millions of
dollars you need to actually get a
physical done and and and how will that
actually go down I honestly didn't think
about that Jason so you know and let's
say there's an agreement but it's just
an agreement and we know we're not going
to take the physical for a week and it
will fall apart between one team and
another team and now they happen this
guy more money you know what I mean I
think the verbals will could get a
little complicated and I'm taking it to
the extreme
but as these teams are sitting back
saying well we don't know exactly what
the cap is yet and we're not positive
exactly what's going to end up with
these figures in terms of the cap I'm
sorry in terms of the franchise in
transition because we don't know which
CBA will be operating under you know so
we don't have all the information we
need so you start kind of planning out
certain scenarios well man if all hell
does break loose on Monday what are the
worst-case scenarios and there's some
that could leave a lot of people peeved
on either side the player community or
the team community interesting Wow okay
so then let's take it one step at a time
Jason locking four from CBS sports here
on the Rich Eisen show what are you
hearing about the vote for the
collective bargaining agreement that is
the first major domino to tumble here on
that front you know everything and I'll
be honest with you today has been such a
scramble keeping on track of the
meetings and the draft and the league
year and what's going to happen what's
not going to happen so much in flux
I haven't doubled back with a lot of
agents and players today to kind of take
you know caucus where things stand now
with this virus being like it is and
with professional athletes now being you
know we've got cases of known infections
and spreading does that change some guys
calculus you know someone who hasn't
voted yet does he say wait a minute
there's so much uncertainty in the world
right now
do I want to sign any kind of 10-year
deal about anything you know I don't
know up until 48 hours ago talking to
especially the bank and file you know
agents who represent primarily guys on
veteran minimum contracts players who
make well below you know the league
average and um most of those guys were
still going to vote with their
pocketbooks which I understand
completely but you just kind of wonder
you don't mean like literally every five
minutes there's some massive
announcement that we never would have
failed right that we never would have
considered even thought about being a
possibility or we should go does that
change this for some people I you know
it may but what were you hearing I guess
before all the Cova 19 madness began -
guys we're going to do what make sense
for them which was hey I'm probably only
in this you know if I'm lucky three to
five years and another hundred thousand
dollars and a easier path towards
pension and less risk in the preseason
where I'm getting hurt in the game that
doesn't matter anyway and more jobs
being created which means maybe I do get
a third contract instead of just one or
two that made real time sense for a lot
of guys when they sat down with their
lives you know and had a glass of wine
and said okay let's look at the pros and
the cons you can understand why a lot of
players would say I understand that the
best eighth grade quarterback on the
planet might hate this deal in 2026
uh-huh
but you know what I mean for me right
now and for our family another $100,000
this year and probably next year and
maybe a chance to squeeze out another
contract after that because most guys
are going year-to-year that's you know
you're gonna be really hard to convince
the missus that that's not what makes
the most sense right right right right
right Jason locking for here on the Rich
Eisen show and then obviously the way
that goes affects franchise tagging can
you explain that conversation to fans
that might be interested in whether that
affects a team that we have thinking
suck on you have to or
right yeah so we've got the CBA vote
this weekend and if it passes the
proposal gets one more vote yeah than
nay then we are no longer in the final
year of the existing CBA we're now into
sort of a transition year into what
becomes a decade-long CBA and so teams
would have under the old rules in the
final year of a CBA been able to apply a
franchise and transition tag and for
under the new rules they'll just have
one
it doesn't affect a ton of teams but if
you're a fan of Dallas Cowboys tantalate
box the Tennessee Titans
it certainly could affect you because
can you keep a Barrett and a Winston can
you keep two out of three Tannehill
Conklin and Derrick Henry on the tag if
you can't get anybody extended you know
can you automatically bam hey dak your
your your franchise and hey Amar'e your
transition obviously if you only have
one of those to play with your DAC is
going to get it no matter what you know
but that that man welcome Ari's he's
probably about at the market no matter
what and Jerry's got enough money to
bring them back no matter what
but it that's another reason why there's
uncertainty and yet another reason why
teams aren't talking turkey financially
with agents the way they normally would
be because the landscape is still a
little Ani there's so little no one
knows you know exactly what we're up
against few more minutes left with Jason
locking for here on the Rich Eisen show
we got our colleague Jeff Darlington on
on the air the other day to update us on
his reporting that eight teams are
interested in Tom Brady and whether he
would be shocked if Brady goes back to
New England he said that there are still
significant number of teams out there
for Brady services don't sleep on the
bucks is what he kept saying a couple of
times and also did mention that he would
be surprised if Brady did go back to New
England today we heard from his
colleague at ESPN Diana Rossini who said
that she's hearing that perhaps it's not
as many teams out there for Tom Brady
services what can you tell us as we are
maybe on the precipice of a big free
agent maneuver here I think would six to
18
you know tap Danya his agent on the
shoulder and say hey we like a guy you
know we would love to have an audience
with the goat sure are there eight teams
that they make sense for him and he
makes sense for them and this is a
two-way street and he's got to be on
board you're recruiting him I don't
really know I I have a hard scene you
couldn't tell me there's eight different
jerseys I could picture Tom Brady in
next year and that he could picture
himself in hello but you still you
listen you play out the you play things
out but but all this uncertainty we've
talked about has certainly pumped the
brakes or on Tom Brady really moving
forward with some of these teams at the
end of the day I have a hard time seeing
it in Tampa I mean be a Bruce Arians can
be very persuasive
I don't see him ending his career as a
Tampa Bay balk
you know the LA thing if the charges
came out him the right way both ears
would be wide open and he would be
willing to be loud do they have it in
their wherewithal or do they even want
to WoW him you know that we'll see I
think the Raiders thing is interesting
on some levels Tennessee the
relationship with with the coach but I
still think tena Hills back there I
thought that all along
is there a mystery team maybe and then I
have a lot of people want to rule out
the Patriots but there's no way in the
world that Tom Brady's signing somewhere
else without giving Robert Kraft you
know his full and undivided attention at
some point in this process and we'll see
where the Patriots are in terms of
market value and if they're willing to
pay Tom Brady the way the market would
if they are then I'm I have a hard time
I have a hard time ruling it out or
saying I'd be shocked to see him retire
as a patriot and honestly Tom doesn't
have all the information he needs to
make these decisions yet did you mention
the 49ers I didn't I guess you could saw
him in there that's another one where I
I what I've heard there doesn't lead me
to believe that that's a strong
possibility but I'd look nothing is
impossible in a situation I'm not going
to say I'm not gonna rule anything out
but from what I've heard I don't I don't
think that's one of the you know you may
be handicapped and I don't know that I
put them you know in the three or four
teams that
take it ultimately gets down well I mean
he I think he would love to have that in
the top two or three I would die in
again and this is all conjecture totally
but you know hometown team finish up
where he always wanted a you know as a
kid play parents nearby they were seven
minutes shy of winning it all why not
use your goat gorilla in the room
elephant in the room bull in the china
shop status to see if you can try and
make that happen right okay I just I
just I don't know I guess I got a
feeling that's not where it ends up but
I'm by no means am I saying it's it's
out of a question and to your point no
one knows like I mean I think if you
gave Don he truth serum right now you
know what I mean he couldn't tell you
unequivocally where this paths going to
end this is there's there's more this is
not linear it's not a to be there's
gonna be more twists and turns and more
meandering and more information
gathering than Tom Brady's I mean this
is the first time he's ever embraced
free agency and I think he's going to
embrace it fully and see where it leads
Jason thanks for the time man Congrats
on your new show you want to tell people
all they can listen to it on 105 7 the
fan in Baltimore you can check it out
nationwide on the radio.com app we've
got our caller well my old colleagues
are still colleague Brian Billick on the
day that Kirk Lorentz from Iowa talking
about Marshall yonder we got we got
everything you need rich if you're a
Baltimore fan or even just a football
fan or maybe a sports fan I just want to
come to your audience at all but Jason
first first of all it's all good
secondly you're on a different time than
many other one that's why I'm giving you
the floor to tell us I mean maybe we do
overlap but either way it's all good you
good man Jason right back at you that's
Jason locking for from CBS Sports